hello and welcome to the business
analytics foundation with our tools
course offered by simpler learn
foundation course comprises sins after
completing this course you will be able
to understand what analytics is
understand where analytics is applied
and the process involved in it get an
overview of the various topics that will
be covered in different lessons describe
the career path of a business analyst in
the next slide we will look at what
analytics is
X is a journey that involves a
combination of skills advanced knowledge
ease locations and processes used by a
firm gain business insights from data
and statistic this is done to perform
business planning in the analytics
process data is collected from various
external sources and is stored in a data
warehouse after this data collection the
process of analytics begins here a more
in-depth learning of the data is done to
derive possible insights from data in
addition to this all advanced
data-driven capabilities are developed
which in turn provides additional value
to business in the next slide we will
look at the places where analytics is
applied
of the common fields where analytics is
implemented are as follows financial
services in this field analytics is used
for credit scoring fraud detection
pricing and claims analysis in retail it
is used for promotions replenishment
demand forecasting and merchandising
optimization in health care it is used
for drug interaction preliminary
diagnosis and disease management
customer retention capacity planning and
network optimization are the primary
applications in the field of
communications trading supply demand
forecasting and compliance are the areas
of application in energy in
manufacturing it is used for inventory
replenishment product customization and
supply chain optimization in the next
slide we will look at the topics that
are covered in the first and second
lessons
someone you will learn what analytics is
and understand the process involved in
it the lesson will also provide brief
details on where you can apply analytics
and what insights can be derived from
this application this helps you in
understanding a problem and knowing how
a data scientist should act
this lesson will also help you in
knowing how to collect data and prepare
it for your analytical process in the
second lesson you will have an overview
of all statistical methods including
descriptive statistics probability
theory concepts of tests of significance
and hypothesis testing some business
uses of these statistical concepts have
also been provided via case studies for
better understanding this lesson will
give you an idea of how you can derive
some meaningful pattern from the data it
will help you in finding the
distribution pattern that is hidden in
the data and in proceeding with further
decisions that are to be made at the
basic level in the next slide we will
look at the topics that will be covered
in the third and fourth lessons
third lesson will help you understand
data exploration data visualization and
diagnostic analytics and perform these
using the our tool case studies and
examples have been provided to help you
understand the concepts in a practical
way and also help you use the AR tool
effectively the fourth lesson will help
you understand some predictive
techniques such as regression analysis
and models that could be built from them
logistic regression time series analysis
and cluster analysis will also be taught
with some example case studies these
predictive modeling techniques will help
you look at the past data and identify
the predicted value that helps in making
decisions further all the working
procedures are explained using the art
tool in a stepwise manner with suitable
examples in the next slide we will look
at the career path of a business analyst
the analytics has evolved over time and
the advent of big data has made
analytics one of the most sought-after
skills in the industry across domains
this course will help you take the first
step toward understanding analytics and
the way it interfaces with the industry
the course will also help you start
thinking like a business analyst
career-wise you can aspire to be a Data
Manager data miner or a business manager
the work of a Data Manager involves data
preparation deployment services report
administration the work of a data miner
involves exploratory analysis
descriptive segmentation predictive
modeling the work of a business manager
involves campaign management domain
expertise process and ROI evaluation
this cludes lesson zero of the business
analytic patient with our tools course
offered by employers thank you for your
attention please continue your learning
with lesson one of this course
hello and welcome to one of the Business
Analytics foundation with our tools
course offered by simply learn after
completing this course you will be able
to differentiate between analysis and
analytics understand what is analytics
learn the different stages in analytics
know the popular tools used in analytics
understand the role of a data scientist
know the processes involved in analytics
define a problem statement collect and
summarize data detect and treat outliers
in the data
we all know we are learning about
analytics then what is analysis is it by
any means different from analytics if
yes in what ways is it different in this
slide we see the basic difference
between analytics and analysis analytics
is the science of analysis wherein we
apply methods of statistics data mining
and computer technology for doing an
analysis whereas analysis is the process
in which the complex data available is
been broken down to simpler forms which
provide more compact and better data for
understanding in the next slide
we will see more into what is analytics
so what actually is analytics it's the
science of wisely acquiring meaningful
results from the given data using
various methods and technologies and by
which a pattern of variation is observed
by studying this pattern we can
understand the future and predict the
uncertainty that is related to business
various sophisticated models and
techniques are used like statistical
mathematical and economical models so
how do you go about analytics first you
gather data for example for a commercial
entity you collect data from enterprise
social media internet forums etc second
you Club all the data together and
consolidate and organize it in a form
from which you can analyze through
visualization statistics etc which is
the third step in the process in the
next slide we will see the different
stages of analytics there are major four
stages in any analytics work the first
stage is called
descriptive analytics where data or
information is gathered and summarized
this stage usually caters to questions
like how many students dropped out last
year the next stage is called diagnostic
analytics where data is analyzed and
insights are generated which help in
answering the questions in the first
stage
here the question that comes up will be
why has the dropout rate increased in
the last one year with the help of the
analysis done in the previous two stages
the next stage tries to answer
unforeseen phenomena like which students
are most likely to drop out the stage is
called predictive analytics finally the
last stage known as prescriptive
analytics tries to analyze the type of
action required to be taken to support
or avoid the unforeseen phenomena
predicted in the previous stage in this
scenario prescriptive analytics has
queries like which students should i
target to keep them from dropping out
next we will look at a list of a few
popular tools used in analytics these
are some of the commonly used tools for
analytical purpose to get meaningful
results our revolution are our studio
tableau s AP Hana
Wacka k Xen SaaS next we will discuss
the role of a data scientist
so what is the role of a data scientist
in data analytics a data scientist is
somebody who is inquisitive who can look
at data and spot trends they come out
with unrevealed stories hidden and data
that helps in creating more useful
insights and thus help in solving
business problems a data scientist works
in sync with application developer to
get the relevant data for analysis he or
she makes an analytical plan in such a
way that the results satisfied the
business needs a data scientist also
comes up with an effective data mining
architecture and prepares suitable
models they are responsible for
resolving data mining performance issues
and finally they should generate reports
that are affordable from a business
perspective next we will see the
methodology involved in data analytics
that that analytics methodology
comprises of six steps as can be seen in
the image the discovery step is
questioning if there is sufficient data
to make an analytical plan once we have
the data in data preparation all
unstructured data is converted into
structured data so that it helps in
planning model planning is choosing an
appropriate model that suits your data
model building is building the model
that is being specified in the previous
step the next step is to come up with
insights that help customers to solve
their problems that is to deliver
results the final step is to make the
model operational and put the findings
to use next we will discuss how to
define the problem
defining the problem statement is an
important step in analytics and needs to
be done before starting the project at a
high level the problem statement should
answer four basic questions what is the
problem find the existing problem that
needs to be solved what is it not define
the problem that is not being caused why
do we have this problem find the root
cause of the problem why don't we have a
solution this gives the answer that is
why the problem could not be resolved in
the next slide we will discuss how to
formally define a problem statement the
techniques that are involved in formally
defining a problem are state the problem
in a general way that is state the
problem in general terms with respect to
some practical scientific or
intellectual interest the next step is
to understand the nature and origin of
the problem its objectives and the
environment in which the problem is to
be studied next all available literature
including relevant theories reports
records and any form of relevant
literature on the problem needs to be
reviewed and examined the next step is
optional the researcher may discuss the
problem with his or her colleagues and
others related to the concerned subject
to brainstorm ideas
finally rephrase the problem that is put
the problem in specific terms that make
it feasible and helps in the development
of working hypotheses next we will look
at ways to summarize data before
summarizing data the types of data need
to be discussed data can be two types
qualitative or quantitative qualitative
or categorical data refers to data that
are descriptive they are generally
recorded in groups or in descriptive
language example dividing people into
high medium and low height groups
quantitative or numeric data refers to
data that
recorded in numbers they could be either
continuous or discrete variables example
the measured height of a person in the
next slide we will discuss how to
analyze this data summarizing refers to
procedures that are applied on the raw
data to convert them into an easily
readable and analyzable format the
mathematical summaries differ according
to the type of data numerical or
categorical and fall into descriptive
and graphical categories seen here is an
example of population / marital status a
bar chart has been used to depict the
same data in the next slide we will see
the different summaries based on the
categories numeric data can be
summarized using the mean median and
mode values these are discussed in
detail in the following chapters along
with other methods for summarizing
categorical data can be summarized using
a frequency distribution table that is
the number of occurrences of a value for
all values graphical representations
help an easy visualization of the data
numeric variables can be viewed as box
plots and the categorical variables can
be viewed in bar charts or histograms
the visualizations will be discussed in
detail in the following chapters in the
next slide we will discuss how to
collect data data collection is the
process of gathering data that is
relevant to the problem statement at
hand the data aids in proving or
disproving hypotheses or provide
solutions to a research or a problem
statement regardless of the problem the
data collection process needs to be well
defined and systematic in an effort to
construct accurate data the accuracy of
the data is the primary factor in
deciding the validity of the findings
depending on the method used to collect
data the observations need to be
recorded and organized in such a
a to provide optimum usefulness the
recording and organization of data must
also be directly related to the methods
of analysis and use of the data we will
see the methods of collecting data in
the next slide the data collection
methods fall into two major categories
primary and secondary observations
experiments and surveys fall into the
primary category observations refer to
measuring the data and various
attributes in experiments the subjects
are divided into groups receive
different external input and the results
are recorded surveys questionnaires and
interviews help and recording feedback
and are used in studying the
characteristics of a population data
sources refer to data that have already
been gathered and are available in a
published format reporting refers to
cases where there exists a database of
information that can be legally obtained
next we will discuss data dictionary a
data dictionary also called a metadata
repository is a file that describes the
structure and content of the data the
data dictionary is a file or a list of
files that contains data about the
database like number of Records name of
each field characteristic and type of
each field description of each field
relationships between different fields
in analysis the data dictionary helps in
analyzing different variables and the
relationships and dependencies between
each other in the next slide we will
discuss the final topic of this lesson
outliers outliers are observation points
in addition significant deviates from
other observations if you look at the
graph it plots the marks obtained as a
result of a particular study time the
trend is that marks increase as the
students study longer except for one
marked point this could be a possible
outlier outliers could exist
in a distribution due to erroneous
observations or special circumstances
like a bulk sales order on a particular
day in a store outlier detection tests
exist to check for outliers that are
modeled based and generally look for
outliers based on mean and variance of
the data outliers can be excluded from
the analysis or included while using
algorithms that treat outliers as well
there are other outlier treatments but
are out of scope for this chapter
let us quickly summarize what we have
learned in this lesson we have discussed
what analytics and analysis are and the
differences between them popular tools
used in analytics what a data scientist
does the processes involved in the
analytics lifecycle how to formally
define a problem statement methods of
collecting and summarizing data for
analytics data dictionary and its
contents
what outliers are and how to detect and
treat them the section help you to check
your understanding of the concepts
covered
concludes lesson one of the business
analytics foundation with our tools
course offered by simpler learn thank
you for your attention please continue
your learning with lesson 2 of this
course
you